اكثر من 100 الف دولار امريكي انفقها
الشاب الامريكي برايان سانشيز على عمليات
اطاله لساقيه وبعد عده جراحات مؤلمه حصل
براين بالفعل على ما يريد وهو زياده طوله
بنحو 17 سم
خضع لعمليات جراحيه مؤلمه في ساقيه منها
كسر قصبه الساق افراغ جزء من نخاع العظم
طبعا هذه العمليات لها وضع قضيب ربط
بمثبتات في الاجزاء العظميه لمده شهرين
تقريبا مع برم المسامير على هذه المثبتات
يوميا
من الام عده منها قله النوم والعناء في
الحركه
تام وصوله طول المناسب انه لم يندم على
قراره مش عارفه يستاهل الموضوع اي انت
طويل
يقولون يا من شراله من حلاله عله
مستحيل اعمل في حالي هيك عشان عشان
مثلا بس مش مستعده اتحمل كل هالقد
خلينا نكبر مشاهدينا خلوني مثل ما انت
بركي مقصرك شوي انا يصير وياي دسكات
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات